الى موضوع علميا بحثي يثير العجب والجدل
معا ومع استمرار هندسه الجينات في ادهشنا
ان تجعلنا يابانيون فئران عن طريق بويضات
من خلايا ذكوريه فقط هذا تطور يطرح سؤالا
مهما هل سيتمكن البشر في المستقبل من
التكاثر دون الحاجه الى نساء يعني هذا
الاختراق العلمي سيفتح امكانيه جذريه في
مجال تكاثر والانجاب في المختبرات
والمعامل وفي الاصل اراد الباحثون
اليابانيون تطوير علاج متلازمه تيرن التي
تؤثر فقط على النساء وقصور النمو لديهم
والتواصل لعلاج اشكال جديده من العقم
فحص العلمي اكثر مع زميلنا علاء سرحان
باحثون يابانيون نجحوا في انتاج سبعه
فئران من ابوين بيولوجيين من الذكور
باستخدام خلايا جلد من فار لتكوين بويضه
قابله للحياه تم تخصيبها هم ياملون في دفع
علاجات العقم الى الامام خاصه تطوير علاج
لمتلازمه تيرنر لدى النساء حيث تعاني
النساء في هذه المتلازمه من نقص كلي او
جزئي في كروموسوم اكس بينما تمتلك النساء
بشكل عام اثنين من الكروموسومات اكس
ويمتلك الرجال كروموسوم اكس واحد واخر قام
العلماء اليابانيون بمعالجه الخلايا
بطريقه نسخ كروموسوم اكس وانشاء خليه بها
اثنين من جينات اكس وهو ما يمكن اعتباره
عاده خليه انثويه قاموا بعد ذلك بتحويل
هذه الخلايا الى بويضات واستخدموا
الحيوانات المنويه من ذكور الفئران
لتخصيبها في المختبر ادت هذه العمليه الى
ولاده اكثر من نصف درزينه من الفئران
السليمه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من اوساك دكتور صفوق الشمري
رئيس مركز الطب التجديدي في جامعه اوساكا
دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه لاول مره ينجح العلماء في انتاج
بويضات ثديه من خلايا جلديه ذكريه نتحدث
عن اهميه هذا الاختراق العلمي
حياكم الله صباح الخير
طبعا
الاختراق هو طبعا حق البروفيسوره
الموضوع هذا عشان نكون صريحين ما كان شيء
جديد لكنه الشيء الجديد فيه انه العلماء
اخذوا خطوه اضافيه عندما كان موجود من ان
تم
اختراع الاي بي اس اللي هو الخلايا
المستحثه والفكره هذه نظريه موجوده من
ايام يمنات طلع الاي بي اس
للتوضيح هو سابقا كنا نحتاج خلايا جذعيه
حاليا ناخذ خلايا من
الجلد بعمر الانسان الطبيعي عمره اربعين
خمسين وليفر يعني ونقوم ببرمجتها بعد ما
نقوم بالبرمجاتها نعيدها الى عمر اربع
سنوات اربع ايام بتطير كانها خلايا جذعيه
وبعدها نقوم
طبعا تتخصص الى 250 نوع من الخلايا طيب
الدكتور قبل بس ما نفوت يعني بهاي
التفاصيل
المعقده والمتشابكه السؤال الاساسي من
الاساس يعني لماذا لا يتم مثلا
تصنيع بويضات بشريه قابله للحياه من خلايا
انثويه على اعتبار انه هذا يتماشى مع
الطبيعه البيولوجيه والفطريه لماذا اللجوء
اصلا الى بويضات ذكوريه من الطرفين
الموضوع في
من تقريبا من اربع خمس سنوات من 2016 تم
اخذ بويضات اخذ خلايا الجلد من الفئران
الدويه وعمل بويضات وعمل
حيوانات منويه نفس الدبور وتمت العمليه
لكن اللي صار حاليا انه الى حد ما للاسف
انهم راحوا المرحله
مرحله 2013 انه لماذا حتى لا نصنع خلايا
انثويه من الديكور فمرحله اللي هو خلايا
اللي هو الطبيعي هذه موجوده تقريبا من
فقلت لك المشكله حاليا انه لكنه هذا لا
يعني باي شكل من الاشكال انه اللي ممكن
تسويه بالفار تسويه في الانسان
من 2016
بدنا نفهم شغلات هل هذا الاختراق سيفتح
امكانيه جديده للتكاثر يعني هل يمكن
بالفعل ان يحدث تكاثر البشر من دون نساء
حاليا الى يومك الحالي
المحاولات اللي نحاولها في الخلايا
الذكريه في الخلايا البشريه لم تتحقق نجاح
كل النجاحات اللي فارق من 2016 الى يوم
هذا اغلبها بالخلايا الفئران الخلايا
لاحظنا انه الخلايا البشريه عندما نحولها
الى
لقحها تكون النتائج غير السليمه وعلى فكره
بس عشان تكونين في الصوره ترى حتى على
الموضوع الفئران اللي شفتيه حاليا ترى 630
تجربه تمت فقط سبعه اللي نجحت فالموضوع
نتكلم على نسبه نجاح 1%
بالنسبه
للخلايا البشريه الى زاله الطريق طويل
محتاج تقريبا
خمسه الى عشر سنوات قادمه حتى نحقق
الطبيعي
لماذا بالاساس يا دكتور صفوق
لماذا بالاساس نحتاج الى بويضات ذكريه
يعني ما فائده انه ان التكاثر بدون نساء
بس هاي النقطه يعني اللي مش فاهمينها
انا اقول لك طبعا دكتور هياشي لما سوى
التجربه هذه وهو طبعا من جامعه اوتاكا
زميل لما سوى التجربه هذه دواها بروفيت
وليس من اجل ان تصبح براكتس او تصبح هذا
هذا مجرد اثبات نظري وليس
الصيد طبيعي وهذا اللي حنا مركبين عليه
حاليا انه نستخدم الانثى علشان انتاج
البويضات والذكر
يعانون مثلا من عقم للنساء اللواتي يعانون
من عقم يمكن مثلا توظيف هذه التقنيه
حاليا من اجلك من 2016 نحاول على البشر
انه اذا الشخص او الامراه اذا الشخص لا
يملك حيوانات منويه اننا نقوم بانتاج
حيوانات منويه من الجلد والمراه التي مثلا
شالت المبايض او صارت في عمر ما تنتج هذا
اننا نقوم بعمل بويضات انثويه من الجلد
للمراه فهذا التطور الطبيعي للموضوع
البشر لا زالت